hey everyone and welcome back this is my
second shot at recording for this series
uh apologies for the technical
difficulties last time my iPad recording
was getting turned off more frequently
than my ex-girlfriend whenever I tried
to make sexual advances uh but the great
thing about this series is that I can
really crank these out
um I'm not going to finish that joke off
uh because I have pretty much already
made them all before so as you can see
I'm making my second one of the day
which is great so um you know if you
recall from last time we started to get
into the contextualization of the
database problem how we want to actually
organize our data that we can read fast
write fast keep it persistent and so
today what we're going to do is take a
look at the actual internals of a
database and how we want to put our data
on the disk in order to maximize
performance all right welcome back
everybody I have now gotten the iPad and
I'm ready to do some work you may see
this is a different day I'm just coming
home from the office right now and I
have to take a very badly so let's
get this is done with relatively quickly
so we established basically three facts
about the data last video that we're
first going to talk about number one is
the following that we want the data to
be stored persistently
number two
even more importantly is that we want to
be doing this on a hard drive that kind
of follows from persistence we know that
RAM does not store data between
computers shutting off and on so it's
more durable on a hard drive the third
thing is of course that the hard drive
is in a database
or at least we're running database
software on some computer and the actual
data itself is being stored at that hard
drive
so before we go ahead and move further
let's go ahead and look at our hard
drive in more depth so I'm going to draw
another picture of it this time a little
bit bigger so hopefully that helps we've
got basically some rectangle with a
metallic disc and then some moving arm
that goes to the proper place on disk in
order to read or write data so generally
the point of this is that because this
little arm has to actually move around
the metallic disc the closer that you
put data together on disk the faster it
is to access so for example you know if
I have one piece of data here and the
other here that's kind of bad instead it
would be better if you know we had our
first piece of data here again and the
second one right next to it
we're more likely to get better read
speeds okay so now let's actually go
ahead and start thinking about you know
the data is going to just look like an
array on disk right we have all of our
little bytes that we can write down and
slots and so again you know the closer
the data is to one another when we want
to access it together the better so
that's how I'm going to preface this
entire lesson but we'll see this coming
to play more and more so let me go ahead
and scroll down a little bit so now
let's imagine a website right where
basically all it does is it stores a
bunch of names of people and their shoe
sizes and every time you load up the
website it'll show you all those people
and their shoe sizes so I'm now going to
draw up an example database table for
this website so you can see we're going
to have a few rows of people and their
respective shoe size so the first person
is going to be me Jordan
uh and you know my shoe size is 18
because you know big shoes means quite a
little bit about what else is going on
in your body and we know that uh
unpacking number two is going to be
Donald
for Trump he has small hands so he
probably has small shoes as well we're
gonna go ahead and throw him a seven and
then we've got Shaq for Shaquille O'Neal
that dude is massive probably has like a
size 24. I can concede to Shaq so what
is my point about this table well the
first thing is let's say I want to find
rows
where name is Jordan
this is something you can do in most
databases
right in order for me to go ahead and do
that I have to check each row
individually I have to go here then row
number two then row number three and
what that means when you have to do
proportional work to the number of rows
in the actual table itself is that this
is going to be an O of n time complexity
right if there are n rows we have to do
n amounts of work basically or work
proportional to the N rows in order to
actually find the row that we care about
so in addition to that let's say I
wanted to actually edit a size turns out
Shaq is bigger than we thought his shoe
size is actually going to be 26. so
again if we're going to write first what
that means is that we have to actually
find the proper row right we're going
all the way through these rows again and
then we're going and changing our
existing Row from a 24 to a 26. so that
means o of n time complexity for both
reads
and writes
okay so let me quickly erase this 26
and throw back our 24 because what I'm
now going to show is a slightly better
design of a database table that would
basically allow us to improve at least
our right complexity
so let's say this time instead of
editing Shack I want to edit Donald so
we knew normally that in order to make
that edit we would actually have to find
the road Donald in the table and edit it
but now what I'm proposing is instead of
actually doing any physical edits what
we do instead sorry I don't know how to
use this iPad yet is we would go ahead
and add a new row to the table
where I would now just say Donald
with the new shoe size let's say his
foot is actually even smaller than we
realized now it's a six and then every
time we search for a row now we actually
just go ahead and search from the bottom
of the table up so in the case of Donald
I would say oh it's got to be this row
here not this one because this Donald is
actually lower to the bottom and so now
because we know that we're always going
to be writing in the same place every
time which is the bottom of the table we
can basically keep a pointer to that
address and disk and that makes right
times o of one
uh however this does come on the
trade-off of a worse read time the
reason for that is that even though
reads are still o of n
it means that uh they're going to
actually be more rows in the table
overall so that n is going to be bigger
obviously this isn't going to be
acceptable as o of n reads are basically
slower than Joe Biden trying to read
from a teleprompter and he is a boomer
so it's not ideal but the truth of the
matter is actually in a lot of these
problems or a lot of these big websites
We Care a lot more about read speeds
than write speeds and at least as far as
I've just showed you those read speeds
were pretty unacceptable o within is not
good enough right we're going to cross
that out just go ahead and say it right
there the reason o of n isn't good
enough is because when we have hundreds
of thousands or even millions or
possibly more rows in our database we
don't want to have to literally Loop
through every single one in order to
find the proper row that we want we need
to make things faster than that think
about Facebook for example
all right this is the example I keep
using if I have to go through every
single Post in the database in order to
go ahead and load our news feed that is
going to be impractical and it simply
doesn't make sense we need a better way
of actually organizing our data
and this is where the need for indexes
come in
so before I actually explain what an
index is let's think about some things
that an index or just a better way of
reading from databases in general could
help us do well for one we care about
finding rows
with specific key values right so in the
last example
uh basically that was finding a row by a
name
sorry I can't write terrible handwriting
in the last example it was finding a
specific row with a name that matched
the parameter that I provided but in
another example you know maybe it could
be names maybe we care about finding a
row with a specific shoe size that could
help as well and we want to be able to
do this faster than just by linearly
scanning through that whole table
another possibility
is performing something known as a range
query
so we gave some names before an example
of a range query would be show
rows
with
names
between
A and B
right
so
if they're you know Abraham Lincoln in
there you know Alex Adams anyone like
that you want to go ahead and return all
those rows
and this is a very common query if you
think about it in something like a
social media site maybe we want all
posts from you know one hour ago until
now right so it's basically any sort of
range query where we have these kind of
two delimiting parameters and we
ultimately want to get every single
thing in between so these are very
common cases where we care about
optimizing them even if it means
potentially taking a penalty in our
write speeds right because at the end of
the day if we're doing a lot more
reading than writing something in the
database that can help us improve our
read speeds even if it makes writing
more expensive is still going to be a
big win in the average case for the user
experience
and so ultimately what we want is going
to be called a database index a database
index like I've started to hint at
basically does the following basically
does The Following
the read speeds
go up
and the write speeds
go down and this is for a specific key
right so we can have a database index on
one field for example like names in that
table but you know when you mention an
index typically it is on one field at a
time you can create multiple indexes
where there is an index on both the name
and the shoe size you could even
potentially have an index on both the
name and the shoe size but we'll kind of
explain what all of that is in the next
video where I am going to show you one
example of how to implement an index and
kind of the pitfalls and the benefits of
that specific implementation which is
going to be a hash index
all right everybody thanks again for all
the support on the first video of this
series again I'm sorry about the
flickering but uh hopefully we can get
that fixed up this time around I am now
going to go ahead and take a fat crap
and I will see you in the next one